welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr.
disappointment and I hate to be the
bearer of bad news but it's difficult to
not feel frustrated with today's
breaking news that is that spider-man
will no longer be part of the MCU as
Disney and Sony have cut ties with one
another within the last hour deadlines
have reported that the two companies
have failed to reach an agreement with
one another and therefore are parting
ways obviously this is crushing if
you're a Marvel fan as it destroys all
of the potential that the spider-man
films had been building since civil war
for those who don't know Sony owned
spider-man but they allowed the
character to appear in the MCU in
exchange for Disney making the films in
order to get the character back at the
height of popularity after they'd pretty
much derailed it with the Andrew
Garfield movies Disney only wanted a
small cut for the films and they were
contracted to do civil war Homecoming
infinity war end game and far from home
after far from home the contract was at
an end and there were rumors that Sony
would only renew it with Marvel if the
film grossed over 1 billion dollars
which it managed to do making it the
first spider-man film to do so you would
think that Sony would be pleased with
this but apparently negotiations broke
down due to money and because Disney
wanted 50% of the profits for the film
instead of the small amount that Sony
were allowing them to have even though
they were doing the majority of the
heavy lifting what's so frustrating
about this is that Sony had pretty much
ruined spider-man and Disney had got the
character back on track with some
phenomenal films and they even had the
character in Avengers and game which has
gone on to become the highest-grossing
movie of all time it just seems like
such a bad play that is purely down to
greed and reportedly Sony flat-out
turned down the 50/50 deal and didn't
even come back to try and figure out a
compromise it just seems that they
didn't want Disney to have any part of
their biggest cash cow and we're
expecting the company to stick with the
5% they've been making on the prior
movies which is honestly quite laughable
there's been a lot of back and forth
between the two companies and the entire
thing has been a shambles with Disney
unable to call
MJ mary-jane due to Sony wishing to keep
the character a certain way and so on
and yet it just shows that Sony don't
really understand what they're doing
apparently they are working on two more
films that will have John watts and Tom
Holland at the helm so the cliffhanger
from far from home will still have a
conclusion though I don't really trust
Sony all that much to be able to deliver
on it and they really don't have the
roster anymore with it being unconnected
from the MCU if you've been following
their films it's pretty clear that this
has been a play that they've been
attempting with the company starting up
their own films in the spider-verse
such as venom and mobius and and now
think it looks like Sony were pretty
much letting Disney go out and do the
work so that they could get all the
profits essentially Sony are pretty much
Jerry holliwell thinking that she can go
on to have a bigger career without the
Spice Girls that reference is terrible
but it's completely baffling why they've
done this move when all they had to do
was kick their feet up let Marvel do the
work and take 50% of the profit for it
the MCU is the most consistent film
franchise of all time with every movie
making money and doing well quickly and
it's ridiculous that at a time when
Disney have just made the characters
first billion-dollar film that they've
decided to take their ball and go home
I've just checked this as well and far
from home is actually Sony's
highest-grossing movie of all time which
yet why would you not want 50% of your
highest-grossing film ever when you've
had to do absolutely no work and every
spider-man film you made over the past
10 years bought into the spider-verse
has been a complete train wreck like why
are you doing it Marvel have produced
three out of four of the
highest-grossing movies this year and I
really hope that this backfire is
massively for Sony to the point that
they're forced to renegotiate I'm not a
big fan of boycotting things but if the
next movie is unconnected from the MCU
then I'm not all that interested in
going to see it as I'll no longer be
invested in the characters journey as it
won't have a bigger effect on the logic
world I guess we know now why the next
spider-man film wasn't in the face full
lineup great work sorry what sucks the
most is that Marvel was setting up
spider-man to become
next Ironman but this is just abysmal
foresight on Sony's behalf there's
rumors that Marvel even stepped in and
helped with the edit of venom and this
just comes across as biting the hand
that feeds
I guess that Oscar for into the spider
verse has gone to their head and they
now think they can do it without the
company which is why they're creating
several spider-man spin-offs and a
rumored sinister six film honestly this
just feels like a train crash like I
remember when Spiderman got hit by that
train that's that's what it feels like
anyway it's a really bad day to be a
Marvel fan right now I think that Sony
should have just been happy with 50/50
but if that's how they want to play it
I'm sure Disney will probably just buy
them in a couple of years anyway
spider-man gonna be like I don't feel so
good in the next film cuz gonna be crap
I'm sick of it obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this issue I can
imagine that a lot of you are gonna be
mad which is completely understandable
so ran away in the comments as I'll be
reading all of them and replied to so
here if you want some actual good Marvel
news then make sure you check out the
full gameplay demo for the Avengers game
which will be linked at the end the
whole thing looks awesome so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to see more and just need something
to cheer you up if you want to come talk
to me about movies TV shows games and
comic books then you can follow me on
twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and is
the perfect place to suggest new videos
and content so hopefully I see you over
there after this also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of John wick 3 on blu-ray and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the Sony News in
the comments section below
who wouldn't be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]